are you a fan of tick-tock i'll confess
that i am not uh for many reasons that
are both personal as well as
professional
but i think that the reasons i don't
like it professionally
are kind of relevant to the future of
the company and means that they have a
big problem in their future what up i'm
drex i'm a flow and movement artist from
washington dc and importantly i am also
a content creator and
i have some really big feels about tick
tock that i want to share with you all
but i also have a mission today
i've rented out the dance studio and i
have a piece that i'm working on so how
about you come walk with me as i start
on that mission and i talk with you a
little bit about what my issues are with
tick-tock and why i think they're
important before we dive in though i do
want to just give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard les muchinski
becca
thank you all so very much for your
support from my work and my mission
all right so um i lied just a second ago
i don't technically live in washington
dc i live a couple hundred feet over the
state line in maryland instead
specifically on the border of tacoma
park in silver spring the studio that
i'm heading to is in downtown takoma
park itself so i have a little bit of a
hike ahead of me to get down there which
just means that i've got more time to
talk with you all this intersection is
so sketchy
thank you all right so i've been
creating content online now for close to
a decade and a half i started out
primarily on youtube but i've also been
doing a lot of stuff on instagram for
the past few years as well
i've found both of them to be
interesting platforms as a content
creator
and
i will also say that i am that like
what one percent of the world
that doesn't like tick tock i've used it
i post stuff to it i just don't like it
and for me personally it's just not a
good platform i don't like the fact that
there's audio by default i always feel
embarrassed when i bring up a video when
i'm in the company of others um it also
just kind of encourages a
kind of shallow content that like
you know i i realized that that's a
feature and not a bug for many people
but like i really like to get deep into
stuff rather than just have
something pop up that momentarily
entertains me in terms of the content
that i like
so tech talk has really just really
never been a good fit for me
unfortunately but that is not why or at
least not completely why i think the
platform has some trouble ahead of it
that has more to do with its
relationship with its creators okay so
as a youtuber
there are several different ways that i
make a living that is several different
income streams that i have
one of those and probably the first type
of income stream that youtubers
encountered on the platform
was the advent of revenue sharing that
is the ads that pop up on youtube videos
google shares about half the ad revenue
with you if you reach a certain
threshold of engagement with your videos
and this works out really well for both
youtube as well as for the creators um
basically it is an incentive for you to
keep on producing content for the
platform
to keep getting people coming on and
checking it out it also is great for
youtube because it means that these
creators are people with whom their
audience have a relationship and they're
going to come back for repeat business
right now the thing is it's super duper
easy when posting ads on youtube to know
whose channel is responsible for getting
those eyeballs to it like
you know if if you get an ad that goes
over the pre-roll of your video then you
know they were there to watch your video
right but with tick tock and other
swipeable micro content platforms
that's a lot harder like as somebody is
swiping through videos if they happen
across an ad in between two of them
who should get the credit for having
delivered that ad should it be the
person whose video was just swiped off
of
maybe that swipe represented somebody
trying to move on to the next thing
having enjoyed the last video or maybe
that swipe represented trying to get off
of that video because they didn't like
it
it's kind of hard to measure these
things so tick tock's answer to this has
been to basically set up what it calls a
creator fund this is basically just like
a static pool of money that they pay out
to creators
every month based upon the number of
views and engagement that they get on
their videos which you know this is
actually a savvy answer to this question
but there's one huge problem that
creator fund is static like in sharing
ad revenue youtube actually has a really
easy and understandable solution to
getting its creators to keep on creating
for them
you know
by splitting their ad revenue it means
that as the views for the platform go up
the creators inevitably get a slice of
that pie
that doesn't happen with the tick tock
creator fund unfortunately though as it
stands right now
it's just a static fund that you know as
tick tocks revenues increase the fund
doesn't seem to in commensurate amounts
all right so i usually ride my bike down
to downtown tacoma park and there's only
one bike available here at the bike
stalls that always makes me nervous
because uh
generally speaking there's a pretty good
chance then that uh the bike is broken
or unable to be checked out so let's see
if i am lucky today
hey i'm lucky today all right it would
be kind of dangerous for me to keep on
talking to the camera as i bike down so
instead i will just give you a view part
of the way down and catch back up with
you at the bottom yeah
[Music]
all right made it down to downtown
tacoma park
that bike was janky af
now i've got a couple blocks to watch to
the studio okay so why is it a problem
if the creator fund doesn't grow well
basically because as you get more
creators on the platform the amount of
money that any one of them can make off
of their videos decreases that means
that like you could be pulling in just
as many views but you're going to see
your income steadily go down and that
becomes a disincentive after a while for
people making more content now a lot of
you may be asking what's the big deal
with that
surely with a platform as popular as
tick tock they can just get more
creators coming in all the time and you
know learning the ropes for the first
time themselves and yes that can indeed
happen but and this is a big but
if the platform eventually gets a
reputation for being unfriendly to
creators they're gonna have problems
keeping people on youtube had this
problem with the ad pocalypse just a
couple years ago and it's still trying
to recover its reputation
there are other options out there for
creators other than tick tock in fact
many of the tick tock creators that i
follow have started up youtube channels
specifically so that they have other
options and you know i hate to say it
but i think tiktok has a lot of these
problems built into the very design of
the product that's offering
like
the whole unique value proposition of
the platform is that it's going to give
you quick easy and disposable content
it's almost like taking the idea behind
a dating app and throwing it behind
content everything is rapidly swipeable
so you can get off of whatever you don't
like and hopefully closer to things that
you do it's kind of the gamification of
content rather than say voluntarily
deciding you're going to click on a
particular thing like you would on
youtube so what happens if a platform
that is built around creating disposable
content
suddenly runs drive content
well people are going to stop using it
so at some point tik tok is going to
have to do something to make itself a
more hospitable platform for creators
and when that happens it's going to be
changes that many of the end users are
not going to like after all any choice
that they make that gives the creators
more control inevitably takes some
control away from the audience
that is a spectrum that goes back and
forth this is a binary and it's going to
be very very hard for them to come up
with solutions that give more power to
both parties cool so i'm at the studio
so i'm going to go ahead and mask up
right quick people that watch the videos
that i shoot at this studio are always
asking me why i'm wearing a mask indoors
and this is the answer because they
require me too
sweet
cool so i got an hour to work with in
here and a piece that i'm working on
choreographing so i will show you some
highlights from that and then i'll go
ahead and wrap things up as i'm heading
home
[Music]
well
it's about an hour later and i figure
i'm at least a half a liter uh lighter
of water inside so i'm doing my best to
put it back
so let's talk some more shop so it
should probably surprise nobody that i
as a content creator believe very highly
in the importance of content
and of course the important the
importance of taking care of people that
create it
and right now i feel like tiktok is
basically engaged in a bit of a wager
it thinks that people will take
validation as a form of payment that
getting millions of views very very
easily
is going to wind up meaning more to
people
than getting
like actually paid for it and a lot of
people are gonna discover the hard way
the same thing that i discovered about a
decade ago
you cannot eat likes or views not that
it's a bad thing if you know somebody
who has a regular old day job finds
themselves suddenly an internet
celebrity when they post the right tick
tock that feels good and there's no
reason that it shouldn't but for most
content creators they are going to have
to make a choice at a certain point
between dedicating their time to
creating content versus dedicating their
time to doing something that is going to
feed them or pay the rent and if tick
tock can't do the job for them they're
going to find something else but what do
you think am i making a mountain out of
a molehill here
are there plenty of people that are
making a good living on tik tok and i'm
just not seeing it or am i just an old
fuddy duddy who can't get behind the
changing times leave me your comments
and let me know what you think also if
you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and of course to help my channel
grow and if you just happen to be
stopping by and know nothing about the
flow arts please check out some of my
other videos because i teach stuff that
is very very good for your body and your
brain and
if you find something that you like
there's so much the better for everybody
[Music]
this video would not be possible
for the kind support of all of these
wonderful people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the wonderful people who sit
down in the description help to make
this video and all the videos on this
channel possible if you like these
videos that i create and you'd like to
sign up to support them you can do so by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better he'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
poi spinning and flow arts to the wider
world check that out please and thank
you if you like this video and you'd
like to check out more like it i will
leave a link to a playlist of other
vlogs that i've done down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on youtube
the algorithm also thinks that you'll
like this top video here so you might
want to give that a look too thank you
so much for watching have a good one and
i will see you with a new video on
wednesday take care peace